in the session of the meet the fellows
event and this session will have four
talks taking us through a tour through
learning proves cryptography and so on
and the first talk is by Marco carmosino
who's telling us about learning versus
proofs of complexity lower box
hi everyone thank you for the
introduction I'm Marco carmacino I'm
delighted to be here I'm a research
scientist at IBM and I'll be talking
today about joint work with uh many
people including Anthony and Valentin
who are here
okay so the central conceit is of this
work is that simple concept classes
should be efficiently learnable so you
have a concept out in the world that's
low in some complexity measure should be
able to teach it to students right this
is of great concern to all of us
um we have to define the terms from that
slide so let's talk about defining
learning okay so C is Curly C is going
to be a class of Boolean functions
um I'm going to define a very relaxed
version of valiant's pack model from
1984. uh what I give you is I give you
query access to any function in the
concept class right so you can ask me
for for particular examples you you
control the questions you ask I give you
random bits so you can toss coins I
think the last three talks have have
told us how important those are so those
are useful for the learner to have and I
give you non-trivial time right what
what I mean by that is if we have
Boolean functions on n Bits I measure
the amount of time and resources you
take in the size of these examples okay
um and what I want from you is I would
like you to Output a circuit h a
hypothesis approximating the function f
such that probability if we sample some
new example X from the uniform
Distribution on bits
um that your hypothesis agrees with the
true function is at least one minus
Epsilon it's good so you have good
agreement with the concept
let me give a deliberately provocative
example of a concept class and a
particular concept so first let's start
with the concept class being P poly
that's a general Boolean circuits of
polynomial size and or not Gates the
only thing I restrict is how many gates
you have
yeah and the function from n Bits to
zero one is this kitten function where
if I have one input X1 over here is this
kitten one input X2 over here which is
this dog of Kings
um this says yes and this says no okay
and I want to emphasize that I'm not
lying to you about the function being
Boolean these are dithered images that
are all completely yes or completely no
pixels okay
so I told you what learning is now what
is Simplicity it turns out it's very
complicated to uh Define Simplicity
we're not going to Define it with
bounded VC Dimension by the way as in
the talk earlier today which was very
exciting because that is a combinatorial
parameter about the capacity of the uh
of the concept class right that'll
determine uh sample complexity for pack
learning remember we're bounding your
coins and we're bounding your time here
we care deeply about the computational
resources not just the sample and
statistical resources so I'm going to
tell you that Curly C is simple if we
can prove complexity lower bounds
against curly C without working too hard
uh here's an example ac0 so that's
constant depth and or not gate circuits
of polynomial size that's simple it
can't even compute parity on end bits
and there's a constructive proof of that
great so this is maybe a somewhat
complicated definition of simple now
right because I've just sort of moved
the work I've moved the work from the
concept classes simple to saying that we
prove it without working so hard so now
I have to define proof complexity I'm
not going to do that at all in this talk
but I'm very excited but I'm very
excited about those questions
yeah no I have to Define that too that's
the only thing I'm going to Define
right yeah a simple proof is kind of a
note when I see it and I can extract a
constructive proof from it so that's the
next slide thank you for the question so
here's our class of Boolean functions
here's an Associated meta-complexity
problem I want to distinguish C
compressible Concepts from Randomness I
want to be able to tell the difference
so given the truth table of a Boolean
function that's that's a weird
representation right this is them this
is like the mcsp problem you're giving
the most explicit version of the
function possible
um I say no if that function is in the
concept class and I say yes to at least
one-fifth of all n input Boolean
functions so I have sort of a a
Randomness detector or a non-simplicity
detective
the natural proof paper of rasborough
rudich says that constructive again
that's in quotation marks because I'm
not going to Define it at all proofs of
complexity lower bounds give us
efficient seed distinguishers they give
us efficient algorithmic solutions to
this problem
and this is a quote from that paper that
I love that I'm going to read out to you
even though it's on my slides as long as
we use natural proofs we have to cope
with a duality any lower bound proof
must implicitly argue a proportionately
strong upper bound
and what I like to do is turn those
upper bounds into learning algorithms
yeah so so this is this is what I want
to be able to say this is what I'm
excited about doing at this program and
more broadly in my life I'd like to
reduce learning to meta complexity
problems so if somebody comes to me and
says I have a learning setting I say
great okay go prove this particular
circuit lower Bound in this nice proof
system and then you'll have a learning
algorithm
this actually works
um this class ac0 mod P which is
remember how ac0 was too weak to compute
parity we throw in parity Gates and we
get a stronger class this is learnable
over the uniform distribution with
membership queries in quasi-polynomial
time
um that's joint work with Russell and
Palazzo antonina and and Valentine
that's CCC 2016 and that's exactly the
model on the first slide that I showed
you
these next two
are um slightly better models right in
in this second result we can uh unrelax
the model a little bit such that the
teacher might lie to you they might
adversarially corrupt some fraction of
your membership queries in this third
result
um which I should be talking about in
one of our workshops this is Joint work
with uh antonina Eric Benedict uh
ramiramia and mademoisabin uh we
show that this class is learnable over
any succinctly described product
distribution this is just a slightly
more natural distribution than the
uniform distribution overall pixels
it's a somewhat uh generic pattern here
right if we have a natural property
against a complexity class we get
a learning algorithm for that for that
class
um what's nice about this is that the
runtime and the noise tolerance they
depend on the quality of the lower Bound
in a very natural way right so if you
can show that a certain function
requires huge circuits you get a very
fast learning algorithm which is great
um
and it's only somewhat generic because
this pattern holds for any complexity
class that contains ac0 mod P and that's
that's unfortunate um more about that on
the open problems slide so this is room
for improvement
I'm not going to tell you anything about
the proof techniques except I'm going to
show you this picture
um
we abused the Nissan victorson prg in
the reverse Direction
and a nice idea from that is just a
hybrid argument
we pick two endpoints two different
distributions this is a picture of a
kitten and this is uh randomly sampled
uh pixels but it's not really randomly
sampled because I got it from a website
called random prgs sorry random pngs.com
uh so they're probably using some kind
of cheap pseudo randomness
we interpolate between these two
and we find a place where we get a sharp
threshold between
um seeing a kitten and seeing Randomness
that
this is just a nice picture of what a
hybrid argument can look like it comes
up in these proofs constantly
there are many many open problems in
this setting
so uh first is that Lacuna that I
pointed out on the previous side can we
get generic learning from natural proofs
below ac0 mod P so can we get this
technique to work smoothly for AC 0 we
can just automatically generate a
learning algorithm from the natural
proof instead of having to appeal to the
proof against ac0 with parity that would
be really nice that would be a tighter
characterization
um can we learn from random samples in
this model can we can we turn natural
properties into learning from random
samples for weak concept classes this is
related to the question of do there
exist weak prfs in ac0 mod P
uh following this really nice work of uh
and wonderfully named conspiracies
between uh learning and algorithms of
Livery and santhanum can we get uniform
learning dichotomies where uh a concept
class is learnable if and only if it
doesn't contain certain kinds of
pseudorandom objects in it and it's
learnable by an algorithm not a circuit
that would be really nice I'd love to
work on that
can we redo can we get better lossless
compression that's kind of a search to
decision version of mcsp uh where you
you instead of asking questions you just
get the whole you get the whole function
and you need to give me now a perfect
circuit for it right
um there are much better lossless
compression algorithms for Aces zero mod
P than you can get by just running our
algorithm then filling in the errors in
the truth table but you can't get them
generically from proofs of the lower
bounds
um
I'd like to be able so in Valentine's
talk in the boot camp he said you know
we do this kind of boosting where first
we start with a weak learner and then we
uh improve its accuracy using a
construction that's like boosting that
construction comes from coding Theory
it's like error correcting codes it
would be really nice if we could use
standard boosting algorithms from the
learning World on on our learning
algorithms in this setting
and I'm uh yeah it would be really nice
if we could learn ACC 0 non-trivially
somehow applying or extracting ideas
from uh Ryan's breakthrough circuit
lower bounds for that class
and finally I'm really interested in
improving the learning setting Nuance
um that's just saying
if there are new and exciting learning
classes I want to try and reduce them to
interesting meta complexity problems and
that's pretty much all I have for today
thank you
so we have time for questions
um
what what is the uh better lossless
compression that is not generic uh I I
believe SRI countries in Boston
um has an algorithm that compresses to
sub exponential like it actually
achieves the lower bound uh but again
that that algorithm while great directly
inspects by a human the proof of the
lower bound and then extracts a clever
algorithmic idea I want a machine that
automatically turns uh the lower bound
into a
lossless compression algorithm with the
same parameters
also say a little bit more about how
learning from random samples
um
there's the paper of
um currents so weak prfs right the
queries that you get to them are random
you don't have control over examples
anymore right so there you go it's the
it's the natural it's the natural model
and like I've been thinking a lot more
about crypto recently and here I want to
be talking to cryptography people and
learning how to flip the story between
the cryptography primitive and the
learning primitive
um and I hope that we can obtain Tighter
and Tighter connections this way between
both disciplines so yeah
you have a question
maybe a follow-up to the lossless
compression question is that related to
improper learning in some way because
you are allowed to oh I didn't mention
this at all okay wow
okay sorry our algorithms
um one of the parameters that depends in
a very natural way on the proof is when
you extract a distinguisher from a proof
of a lower bound that distinguisher has
a computational complexity that is
proportional to the proof system that it
was proved it and when you spit out our
hypothesis it embeds that distinguisher
um
so
that's often in a different complexity
class like if you just look at our
algorithm it learns
um ac01p into like nc2 because we need
to compute the rank of a matrix in a
naive way
um
yeah so so
it is improper yes yes it's improper
right now and it would be great if if we
could
um
reduce the complexity of the proof such
that we end up automatically with proper
learning algorithms but I don't even
know if that's possible in fact we
thought about this a while ago for ac0
and uh
um it seemed actually difficult to get
proper learning for that so okay
that's
what do you mean by proof
this was the in your paper from Stephen
ucnc2
formal proof Zone yes I mean an informal
proof although if you um talk to Yan and
look at the paper before uh before the
natural proofs paper that notion can be
formalized but here we're just talking
about okay if you can extract this
particular type of algorithm from the
proof that's and I know it when I see it
it modularizes extracting algorithmic
ideas to improve you extract just this
one algorithmic idea and then you reduce
learning to it but of course you can be
more formal and I would love to do that
while I'm here
great let's um take other questions if
any offline thanks again
[Applause]